hello everybody my name is Nia and I'm
the black female engineer and I provide
content for new and aspiring software
engineers and
today I am on a mission the job market
for the last year and a half has not
been it the tech job market specifically
I'm sure other job markets do but I
don't know nothing about that I got my
first sixf figure software engineering
role after going to a boot camp and
apply Ling like crazy and doing
everything I could to get a job which
included writing articles on medium and
networking and posting on LinkedIn and
all of that right however the landscape
is so different I did that all back in
2020 and now 4 years later I don't know
if I could have done the same and gotten
a job as quickly as I did and I've
gotten so many questions about what my
advice for going through the 2024 Tech
job market would be and I don't want to
give the same advice because I don't
know I no longer know what it's going to
take because again it's been so long so
I'm going to do something okay this is
day Zero I'm going to do four different
things and whichever one works best at
the end of 30 days and 60 days I will
tell y'all but I'm also going to bring
y'all along this journey with me okay
the first thing I'm going to do is do
the things that I did do back in 2020
that means writing on LinkedIn at least
weekly a new project that I've built
writing on medium at least weekly
something Tech related something
insightful something to teach somebody
Etc every time I see a job that I like
and want to apply to finding someone who
works at the company and reaching out to
them and hoping for that I can get a 15
minute chat or conversation with them
updating my GitHub so that it looks so
crisp so clean so fo and having it act
as my portfolio because fun fact I
actually don't have a portfolio it just
I don't know I just never wanted to do
it just seems like so much work when I
could just use GitHub if I use it
properly I could just use GitHub but
really refurbishing it okay those are
the main things I'm going to focus on
but I'm also going to provide a list of
literally all the things that I did back
in 2020 to get a job as fast as I did
and Implement that into my routine so
that'll be number one for getting a job
so that's the first thing right that I'm
going to focus on now the next thing is
going to be doing that but also focusing
on the new ways of the market which very
much is AI I want to create some AI
projects and talk about AI more and see
if that assists in getting me a job the
first approach is doing all things I did
in 2020 the second step is tweaking it
so that it is AI focused so that it is
updated for the Times number three I'm
going to see how well freelancing works
for me I love live building mobile apps
I've built a lot within the last year
I've posted about some of make sure you
follow me on Tik Tok and Instagram and
not only here seeing how freelancing
goes and the reason I say freelancing is
because when you are facing and by you I
mean me are facing a really terrible
Market it's important to now do things
differently and maybe give the market
time to breathe but in that time you
need ways to sustain yourself and to
earn an income and so freelancing is a
great way to do that I'll use up work
and Fiverr to get freelancing gigs I do
obviously also have my own social media
following which people can reach me to
get freelancing roles but for the sake
of this challenge I'm not going to
include my social presence as part of
this experiment it will all be focused
on upwork and fiber but if you do want
to have me build an app for you let me
know and I would love to do that but yes
it just when we in the videos I share
about how this is all going I just won't
include the social media ones because it
takes a while to build a social media
presence and if you need a job you kind
of need one now so let's see what we can
do right now to earn extra income so
that's experiment 3 and finally
experiment
four is seeing if I can simply earn an
income by releasing my own things by
releasing an app onto the App Store and
seeing what attaction that gives me okay
I feel like under the umbrella of
possibilities for work and specifically
work as a tech professional that really
covers it all we have corporate we have
freelancing and we have entrepreneurship
which freelancing falls into that a
little bit but like I hope y'all can
also see the difference that I'm making
if y'all want to know what I'm doing
every single week so that you can see if
you have any success with it as well
don't worry because I'm going to post
about it every single week the very
first thing I'm going to do is create
profiles on upwork and Fiverr and update
my resume now that seems simple right
but no the updating the resume one is
very important to me because I'm going
to do it extremely strategically and
this is how I as a person in
Tech wear and have worn many hats I am a
software engineer but I'm also a
front-end developer but I'm also a
mobile developer but I'm also a ux UI
developer and so because of this there
are different resumés I can create for
each role however when looking at Job
boards the
role usually will say one of the four it
won't say all of these things and so you
want to make sure you're optimizing your
resume for the specific title of the
role so what I'm going to do is search
software engineer and the first 10 items
that pop up I'm going to populate it
into chat GPT the description of the
role along with the qualifications and
preferred skills populate it into chat
jpt and see what it fits out for what
similarities between all of those 10
postings exist I'm going to then use
those similarities to populate my resume
and make the software engineering resume
then I'm going to make the ux engineer
resume so those two are the very first
things I'm going to do to make sure that
this goes swimmingly and as efficiently
as possible this is day Zero if you have
any recommendations or anything you want
me to test out please let me know for
example let's say you want me to test
out conferences and networking at
conferences put that in the comments
below and I will let you know if I can
or cannot add that into my experiment
I'm going to split the experiment up
into two sessions first 30 days and then
the next 30 days in the first 30 days
I'm going to focus on all just going ham
and at day 30 I'm going to share with
y'all any and all progress what
interviews if any that I've gotten what
income if any that I've gotten Etc and
how I'm going to change for the next 30
days and then we're going to do it all
over again make sure you like And
subscribe and tune in every week so that
you know exactly how this is going okay
so yeah wish me luck y'all and again
please put in the comments below what
things you'd like me to try out and test
out and what things You' just like to
see during this time okay I'll talk to
you soon bye